was macht Summer Cem eigentlich
beruflich ich meine wo er so wenig Alben
rausbringt das jetzt im fragen-lotto und
warum so viele Mädels auf den Konzerten
von Farid und ihm sind also jetzt in
frankenlotto bis dann bleibt dran
ja du weißt ja du kannst wählen die
roten sind gemein die Grünen sind
harmlos hau rein okay
speziell auf dich zugeschnitten
aber wir haben für uns für jede Frage
sehr viel Mühe gegeben
fangen wir mit einer
mit einer guten Mann
vier gemeine und drei warum seid ihr so
gemein zu mir na das ist ein bisschen
Würze
ja ja
gut also das hier ist schon Champagner
oder was ganz grün ist du hast dich
wieder mit Bushido vertragen woher hast
du diese charakterliche Größe
das ist ja echt schön
ich sage euch ganz ehrlich ich habe mich
mit gar keinem vertragen
ich bin weiterhin der dich bin ich hatte
aber auch mit Bushido kein großes
Problem dass man da jetzt über eine
riesen Story draus machen muss
Bravo Foto love story hier mit vertragen
und blau und blubb ich bin einfach
cool mit jedem
der mir jetzt nicht unbedingt Steine in
den Weg legt oder der mir nichts böses
möchte cool jetzt nicht in dem Sinne
dass man mega befreundet ist oder so
aber
ist auf jeden Fall zwischen mir und
Bushido ist kein böses Blut oder nichts
dergleichen das ist aber jetzt auch
nicht so dass wir irgendwie uns sonntags
zum Fußball gucken treffen oder so
ich meine er ist ja ein Typ mit dem ich
früher
schon recht viel Zeit verbracht habe
allein weil ich halt da äh meine Mucke
gemacht habe von daher muss man das
eigentlich auch nicht rechtfertigen aber
wie gesagt ich habe mich mit keinem
vertragen mit dem ich Streit hatte und
jede mit dem ich Streit hatte habe ich
auch denke ich mal aus dem Weg geräumt
nächste Frage nächste Frage
auf der Kirmes
plötzlich ist großes vertragen angesagt
gehen jetzt alle Rapper auf Kuschelkurs
mich interessiert eigentlich nicht was
ein anderen Rapper machen ich war mein
Film weiterhin und der ist auf jeden
Fall alles andere als kuschelig
da können sich alle Leute von überzeugen
ich bin auch nicht jeder der mich kennt
weiß das auch ich bin auch kein Freund
von diesem Pyjama Partys äh aber es muss
auch nicht unnötig immer einer fallen
das habe ich auch dazu gelernt also es
muss jetzt auch nicht immer unnötig
einer fallen aber jeder denkt kann ich
mal vorbeikommen und dann wird gekratzt
warum kommst du beim weiblichen
Geschlecht so gut an
ich weiß es nicht wahrscheinlich dadurch
darüber habe ich auch letztens noch mit
Fahrrad darüber gesprochen weil so viele
Mädels auf den Konzerten sind
ich muss echt sagen wir also unsere
Fanbase auf jeden Fall weiß ich nicht
bei anderen ist oftmals schwanzparade
angesagt da sind nur Typen bei uns sind
erstaunlicherweise auch viele Mädels
dabei wahrscheinlich wird durch und
unser Flo macht uns attraktiver okay
deshalb
schöne Grüße an alle weiblichen Fans
und wie gesagt du willst in Zukunft noch
eine Familie
alles mit dabei
warum musst du eigentlich auf die
Sonnenbank gehen du hast doch von Natur
aus eine dunklere Haut ähm
ja das ist eigentlich eine gute Frage
ich sag dir ich gehe aber auch manchmal
einfach nur auf die Sonnenbank weil es
ein frischer macht noch nicht mal
manchmal mag ich noch nicht mal die
Farbe die ich bekommen weil wenn ich
direkt aus der Sonnenbank komme dann
kriege ich eigentlich so ein ähm
also nicht so ein schönes braun sondern
eher dann ist es auch schon ein bisschen
zu viel aber
einfach Angewohnheit kennst du doch
kanakisch
so jetzt nehmen wir noch eine Gemeinde
ärgern
nur zwei Alben in 10 Jahren
Musikgeschäft wenn du nur so wenig Musik
machst was machst du eigentlich
beruflich
ich habe ja einige Sachen gemacht auch
in der Zeit ich habe ja wie gesagt ein
Kaffee eröffnet gehabt ich habe nebenbei
hatte ich auch meine Zeit lang Autos
importiert aus Amerika das wissen viele
gar nicht ich habe meine Zeit lang weil
ich einfach aufnehmen muss dann Film
hängen geblieben bin und ich hatte da
eine gute connection und da habe ich
kurzfristig gutes Geld verdient gehabt
und ähm in der Zeit stimmt habe ich
weniger Musik gemacht aber wie gesagt
Musik wir sind im Endeffekt keine
Schreibmaschinen in dem Sinne sondern es
kommt nur drauf an als kommt immer
darauf an wie man sich gerade fühlt wenn
mir dann gerade noch Musik ist mache ich
Musik und wenn nicht dann nicht ich
mache das wie mein Schwanz steht und im
Moment steht der sehr gut in Bezug auf
Musical
Autohandel ist mehr so da unten genau
du bist ein Vollblutmusiker wurde dir
das Talent in die Wiege gelegt
ey ich sage dir ganz ehrlich es hört
sich jetzt verrückt an aber ich glaube
ja weil mein Opa
hat früher Geige gespielt also mein
Vater behauptet immer du hast es von
deinem Opa
der hat Geige gespielt der hat aber
leider vier Finger verloren beim Unfall
auf der Arbeit
und hat sich dann mit seiner
Entschädigung mit dem mit der Kohle dir
dann bekommen hat in der Türkei wieder
abgesetzt und das erste was er gesagt
hat nachdem er die Finger verloren hat
scheiße ich werde nie wieder geil
gespielt können das tut mir natürlich
leid
schöne Grüße an meinen Opa
so noch eine fiese zum Abgang
kann ein erfolgreicher Rapper überhaupt
aus Mönchengladbach reinkommen
kann ich würde da eher muss sagen
erfolgreicher Rapper überhaupt aus
Mönchengladbach reinkommen weil ich
finde nicht der einzige aber nicht aus
Mönchengladbach bereit okay gut ausreit
bin ich natürlich wobei ich glaube der
ecort mal an der Grenze zu reit gewohnt
aber nur an der Grenze
ey ganz ehrlich ich bin stolz Einreise
zu sein das ist ein Privileg muss man
erstmal können
okay so sieht's aus danke dir
das war das Frage Lotto mit Summer Cem
und wenn er noch mehr Fragen Lotto ja
ihr wisst ja schon sehen wollt dann
klick zum Beispiel hier unten an das mit
Farid Bang indem er die unverschämte
Behauptung aufstellt es ist Softies
hören sido also in jedem Fall sehr
unterhaltsam oder das mit Hans sapei in
dem er sich die Frage stellt glaube ich
auch beantwortet oder wie haben sie
gestellt ich weiß es jetzt gar nicht
mehr aber ihr werdet schon sehen wenn
ihr seht das fragen Leute mit hansapei
indem er sagt soll ich jetzt nicht sagen
was er sagt ich sag was er sagt er sagt
wer braucht den Hype oder war das jetzt
die Frage oder so oder eben Konfusion
aber wenn jetzt ansieht dann wird der
Bescheid weiß Bescheid bis dann bleibt
dran